[Applause]
so why we set you up but is there any
community announcement anybody Irene yes
good so my name is Adam I'm a scientist
okay a smart city startup based out of
Amsterdam we're currently hiring looking
for experience data scientists I will be
in the pub afterwards if you want to
come and be more as will my boss one of
the founders so come who knows you might
even convince him to buy you a beer okay
so we have the first thought we have
Zach who is machine learning engineer at
Google and Harrison basketball thank you
very much yes I will all right thank you
very much okay hello everyone my name is
Zakir kale I'm a machine learning
engineer and developer advocate at
Google and I also AM the co-organizer of
the central London data science Meetup
how many of you have attended one of my
meet ups Oh quite a few
oh there's a couple cool uh so yeah so
oh no so can you all hear me from here
is this all okay cool uh so yeah a bit a
bit more about me my sort of the things
I like to do is is build machine
learning into applications I was
previously a software engineer and then
I started learning machine learning on
like Coursera and I always was
interested in how could you actually get
machine learning working in in
applications the applications that I
wanted them to get working in weren't
necessarily business critical
applications the first one was this so
this is a physical neural network so
taking a slight kit learned model and
training a neural network in that and
then showing the weights on like our
jeebies so you can see like incredibly
useful
well like when I first saw it it was the
first time I ever saw learning happening
so it was kind of cool to see if I can
show at the top there's there's a little
at the very start there's like a bright
activation over here and it kind of
moves it kind of slides over to the
right-hand side again like I can't learn
anything from it but it kind of looks
cool the next application or one of the
more recent ones was this here's a this
really like set the tone for the kind of
talk this might be if the Wi-Fi works
okay the Wi-Fi is as unreliable as
predicted as Michael mentioned okay cool
so let's imagine nothing happens the
other thing I built was this bike that
was for the PI data conference that
happened two months ago one month ago
happen in the past and what it did is it
did object detection facing behind the
bicycle and then if there was say a
dangerous object it would light up the
handlebars on the side of the handlebars
where the danger existed so you can see
here this is the output of the video the
videos flipped so the bus is on the left
the car is on the right so the bus is
green and the car is red and it's the
size of the handlebars that it lights up
on is representative of how close in the
direction of the thing so that one's
like kind of useful and you should if
you're interested in that project you
should follow me on Twitter because I
may or may not be working with a certain
bike company to actually build this into
a real bike so yeah now stay tuned for
that okay enough about me what about you
so how many people in the room are data
scientists that's a lot of data
scientists how many people have done any
kind of machine learning okay how many
people know what linear regression is
okay so so if you don't know what linear
regression is
I like to I like to assume no knowledge
I like that's my style it's my style
I'll skip over this flood but just in
case you've forgotten what linear
regression is I'd like to show off this
really cool tool which it will in
regression to variables you changed it
to vote I know yeah change the two
variables and it changes the line so
okay now everyone knows what linear
regression is I want to highlight not
just knowing what it is knowing that we
could use a line to predict something I
want to draw attention to the fact that
not only can we predict the the tabs are
bothering me let me just real okay not
only can you use a line to predict but
after you've learnt your line you can
maybe get some sort of insight from the
coefficients that it's found so in this
case I'm imagining I'm a farmer trying
to predict the way to pineapples based
on their age again very relatable and
the idea is that although yeah we can
make predictions using this line but
just by looking at the coefficient that
it's found we can kind of see that okay
the the weight goes up slightly slower
than the age and then when the age is
zero the pineapple weighs five whatever
it weighs kilograms magic pineapples but
the idea is I want to sort of talk as it
might come it might come back later in
the talk who knows but we might talk
about how we can use the coefficients
that have learned for insight rather
than just using a line to make
predictions
okay so basketball again smooth
transitions I I play a bit of sport and
I wanted to get out more so someone
suggesting oh maybe you should try
basketball because there's a lot of
basketball courts in London and I went
away I bought a boss bought basketball I
went to the court I tried to shoot
anybody play basketball by the way come
people yeah I tried to try to shoot some
hoops as they say and it was very hard
it's surprisingly difficult even when
you've got no opposition so the idea is
I was kidding I was getting bored quite
quickly and I wanted to do something
I usually do is I'll do something I get
bored with it and then I'll try to put
some like sort of tack on it does
anybody else do this well they start
thinking about apps that you could do to
do with the thing that you're bored with
yeah it's kind of coming so that's the
idea so if I can't be good at it kind of
a cool doing it this is the idea so
rather than build an app maybe do
something artsy so who's ever heard of
long exposure photography who's done it
does anybody done it yeah so it's it's
the idea that if you have done or yeah
if you have it I see a year that you can
take a camera usually quite an expensive
camera and rather than a camera just
opening and closing the lens to take a
photo you can open the open the lens and
or open the shutter leave it open and
then any kind of light that happens in
the in the image gets kept and so you
get these kind of long trails of
whatever you do so their nearest oh if I
could do this with the basketball shot I
might be able to get a really cool light
even if it misses in fact if it misses
it becomes a more interesting trail of
light so it's a win-win so that was the
idea so the I took the reflective tape
that you get on cones you can buy it on
eBay for like a pound and wrapped it
around the seam of the basketball and I
didn't have one of these cameras that
could do the long exposure shot all I
had was my phone and what was kind of
important for the application using this
reflective tape is that I needed a light
source close to the camera for the
reflection to come back and shine very
bright and fortunately like most phones
have a torch built-in right next to the
web right next to the camera so it was
perfect just set it up set it on video
mode and then make sure the torch is on
and you get the ball kind of lightened
up nice and brightly in the night and so
the idea is I went out when it was a bit
dark and shots and hoops you can see I'm
quite good I got five in a row already
the idea is I would take this footage
and I would pass it through some Python
code and work out the trails because I
guess the delight from the ball is a
very distinct color in the in the frame
and so yeah I went through I actually
used the Python package that I used was
psychic video so if you ever working is
anybody you psychic video before no one
well you should
psychic video allows you to put in like
an mp4 file or or I don't have to work
with avi but put in a video file and it
will take a video file and turn it into
a big long don't be all right so it's
very memory intensive here's the link
I've got these links littered throughout
the entire talk so if you're interested
in the code used to produce this you can
like snapshot of that I'll have all the
links available at the end so yeah this
is this is the shot so here's this still
of it it doesn't look quite as cool as I
initially planned like I didn't have the
long glowing stream mainly because like
the frame rate of the video and the code
I wrote was pretty like naive of just
finding a distinct color and not putting
in much of a threshold above or below
and you can see even like there's lights
in the background because of the
streetlights so it wasn't what I wanted
but then I thought looking at it it kind
of looks like data yeah so could I do
something data related so I thought to
myself if I can't look good in it or if
I'm not good at it and don't look cool
doing it the obvious next step does
anybody know what it is that's right do
some machine learning so the idea is I
take this data and crop it out crop
either very interesting bit that looks
like a kind of curve or a line put it in
put it in some Jupiter notebooks and
then I try to do my linear regression oh
it didn't work
so yeah so standard linear regression
model won't work for this I don't know
if anyone was gonna guess that but that
didn't work but is there another line
that does fit this like do I know how to
describe the line that I just shot and
the answer is yes Wikipedia to the
rescue a trajectory equation should fit
my data and the idea is this this
equation that everybody knows I've got a
animation or the thing before so yeah
same exact principle it's just a line
with when it loads there is it's just a
line with two two variables so an angle
of the shot and the velocity of the shot
so it's almost identical to linear
regression and now the question is is
this the same as linear regression hands
up who says this is the same as linear
regression alright okay hands up if this
is called linear regression if I try to
fit this line hands up if it's called
linear regression hands up if it's
definitely not called linear regression
okay I also don't know and I also I
asked some people around the office this
morning data scientists in office
they're also confused so if I set the
access to be the variables oh I don't
know how that works anyway we'll chat
off shorts but yeah genuinely I don't
know is it still technically a
regression it's definitely regression
still I know but yeah that's something
to think about very thoroughly as I'm
talking for the rest of the talk
so the idea is yeah we got this equation
and how can I do it well I've got a
notebook here and the idea is I can code
this equation fortunately there's like
they don't have to fit trajectory curve
and scikit-learn and they're not even in
Kerris either so I have to code up cut
it up myself
and for that I have a little notebook
here
maybe we'll chat afterwards okay can
everyone see their code
yep no it's back cool so what I'm doing
here is I'm downloading the image of my
data I'm displaying it actually I'll
make sure I don't spoil the surprise by
clearing all the outputs cool so I'll
display I'll display my data so here's
the crop type data of my other shot that
I just made I'm going to defy the
tantrum also in here I define okay what
are the two variables that I'm going to
be tweaking and changing to fit my data
again in that little animation I showed
I was tweaking and changing the angle in
the force so I'll declare those then
I'll go down here's the description of
all so here's the equation at the top
and all I'm doing here is I'm actually
just writing it out in tensorflow syntax
so you can actually see like the first
the first part of this the tan x X
that's just this first line X x TF tan
and then this equation is actually
working in radians so I've got a little
function here that converts radians to
degrees and yeah it's just writing out
that equation in the tensor flow code I
will run that okay and then I will just
show it so here is my data alongside the
default version of my up like tensor
flow code okay
so the red line is the the model where
it is which it's quite far off the data
so what I can do that is like super cool
is I can go in here and say okay force
variable there we go force variable dot
assign there it is
super fast and we're gonna give it I
think it started at 50 let's give it 200
and it will run the same so Oh getting
closer all right let's do the same for
the angle variable here we go
assign that to what was it sorry about
like 48 let's give it a Oh - hi I didn't
know that was gonna happen let's do 50
okay ah this is so hard to try to fit
the variables to think if only there is
a way so we have a machine learning we
have optimizes I don't know if data
scientists are aware of optimization but
yeah we can run an optimizer to do the
exact thing that I was going to do
manually we'll run it for say 200 or 100
epochs we'll be generous and it will go
through constantly tweaking and changing
the variable variable and we'll finally
display our final model
oh let's let's fit it some more it needs
some more time okay what both we got now
close enough okay so it's wet through
it's tweaked and changed the variable
until it's fit the curve tour to my shop
now just I'll just look at the look at
the variable so if I go to my angle
shocks angle variable num P num pulley
and I'm P there we go
63 degrees is the angle of my shot the
force behind my shot is 123 does anybody
know what 123 me any will take a guess
hey I mean logically it should be like a
reasonable metric of force however I
haven't scaled the image when I put it
in its just measuring the pixels so so
what's very very nice as it tells me how
many pixels of force I'm throwing the
ball so if this was like if this image
was to scale and I did throw the ball
say a kilometer this would be 123 meters
per second but because I didn't scale
the image its 124 pixels per second
which is useful but we'll just ignore I
mainly focused on the angle and why am I
mainly focused on the angle good
question here's an animation of the
fitting that just happened
I usually when I when I show this badge
showing us to people you haven't done
machine learning or worked with paisa
nor matplotlib and they don't appreciate
how hard it is to make an animated graph
and so if you do appreciate how hard it
is to make an emma graph you can see all
the code to do the animated graph
alongside fitting a model while showing
the model fitting to the graph so
there's the link to all that that's all
in like a cola oh that is the first time
anyone's ever clapped for this but it's
vile of it I love it okay cool thank you
this is a question I get asked a lot so
I've done all this I've worked out the
angle of my shot but it's I don't know
what to do with it so what I'm gonna do
is what I normally do when I've done
something cool that somebody asked this
question is I retro actively make up a
use case so the idea is I went away and
I asked my friend who is a basketball
semi-pro and I said okay if I want to
shoot a ball from from this distance on
the court like close up and I want to
move to further away in the court how do
i do what do I change about my technique
and doing that and she said you don't
need to change your technique your
technique should stay the exact same the
only thing I should change is the force
behind the ball so I'm getting nods yeah
okay the force behind the ball should
change so power comes from your legs or
any anywhere but the angle of the ball
should stay constant and I thought
excellent so that gives me a reason of
why I've done all this so if I can work
out the angle of all of my shots and
work on how consistent I am in theory
this application that I that I'm
developing can be used to measure how
good of a basketball player you are if
you're consistent in theory you're good
yes okay so what have I done if I want
to analyze a shot it's only six easy
steps so first of all to record the shot
then to cycle home because I have to do
it all on my computer trim the video to
the exact point where I take my shot
apply pre-processing so in the first
case I used elective tape on the ball
turns out that was completely a waste of
time there's actually a pre-processing
technique that I've done previously and
I didn't think of
where I take one frame and subtract it
from the next frame and then only the
pixels that have changed remain and I
apply that across multiple frames and
you get like a trail so you don't need
to wrap tape around the ball does
anybody know what this pre-processing
technique is called
okay I don't either
but what I call it is Delta frames so if
you do know the actual word for a please
tell me afterwards because I've been
telling everyone that it's called Delta
frames so trim the video apply these
Delta frames go through crop the shot in
because my model where I fit a curve it
assumes that the start of the shot
starts at the origin so zero zero so I
need to make sure I crop my shot in then
run my model that fits the line to the
curve it runs and then at the very end I
get the angle of my shot so pretty
straightforward the only thing is a
cycling home takes about 10 minutes
trimming the video I have to do that
manually in Python which takes about
five minutes to find find the point in
the video the pre-processing is super
cheap that's just a bit of Pi the code
minus 1 matrix from the next matrix
cropping this shot takes about five
minutes manually adjusting the the
parameters and stuff writing the model
it's about a second to actually fit the
model if it's if it starts at reasonable
defaults so the idea is I want to play
more basketball I don't want have to
cycle home yeah the idea is what can I
do to solve this problem well what I
usually do to solve problems is you
throw a neural networks at them so I'm
gonna throw a neural network there and
then I'm gonna throw a neural network at
the crumbing of the shot so then that
will automate all the manual steps and
then I can not have to go home and play
my basketball so that's I'm gonna do now
I go through first thing I do is need to
request access
all right what you would have seen here
is just a video of that ghostly image of
me shooting a ball but this what happens
when you share slides across corporate
accounts so yeah you would have seen a
video of me going taking shots and you
see just just the white outline of me
taking the shot
and this world would have explained that
rather than first of all trimming the
video to my shot and then running the
pre-processing because the the
pre-processing that the Delta image
stuff is so cheap to do it's just
subtracting a matrix from another matrix
actually just do that for all the videos
and it's really unfortunate you can't
see the video because the ideas I always
showed you as I'm taking the shot I
could just train a image classifier to
say okay whenever you see a nice clear
arc in my shot
predict that it's I'm taking a shot and
then if I'm running around or it's all
fuzzy and noisy then just say I'm not
making a shot so it's like a shot or not
predictor so if you see a nice clean arc
in the in the video it's a shot if you
don't it's not a shot so how would I do
this I would go through and I would
create shots models so yeah this is if
you see this if you see this it's gonna
be a nice clean shot let's just say yes
to a shot if you see anything else
it's not a shot binary classification
here's done binary classification yes
everyone all right
the next bit so the data so this is the
I usually don't go into the detail about
to go into because to collect data for
this I just recorded myself taking a
shot and I didn't want to I knew I had
to label the data so that created this
kind of negative feedback that I didn't
want to collect a lot of data so I
recorded one session of me taking shot
approximately five minutes of video and
so I wanted I needed to augment the data
I needed to you know kind of get more
data from the data I collected and so
I've got a notebook here that shows how
I just took each image translated it
like five pixels to the left five pixels
up and down who here's never heard and
like data augmentation with images yeah
it's like quite like a common thing to
do I didn't need to do that because it
turns out Karis actually has that built
in now so good thing good thing to note
is if you're ever doing an image image
classification in care
there's actually just a generator here
and you can say here's my data I'm gonna
feed it into my model it's gonna
automatically augment your model by
twisting it and doing even more stuff
like color changes and brightness
changes so that was a bit of a time
wasted when I did that the next portion
is how after I've built my model okay
what is the code I used for my model so
I used care us to train the model the
actual model structure I borrowed from
the Eminence example so here here's herd
of the eminence handwritten digits like
the hello world of image recognition so
caris has a really good example on their
github of model structure that trains
for the M notes really well Eminence is
detecting curves and lines so I figured
mines kind of a curvy line so find an
application that does something similar
and look at what they did for
inspiration the only main thing to note
is in their version of mole they're
doing a multi classification I just care
about if it's yes or no so I just got to
make sure that it's a the output is a
one node and a single sigmoid activation
so that's gonna give me a binary
classifier um - how do I actually bring
this model to the basketball court
here's productionize the machinery model
a lot fewer people than people who say
they do machine learning so that's yeah
it's a it's a tricky thing production
izing machine are new models the sort of
the most fun tool I found being a
previously a web developer I started
using tensorflow JS here's heard of
tensor ojs a couple of people
okay so tensorflow j s is a tensor flow
library that runs in JavaScript as the
name suggests what's really cool about
it is it actually has a slightly it's
it's nice it's got a slightly different
API than a normal tense the tense pro
API it's actually got a quite a few
better high-level API so it's got things
like a little line of code that will
take an image and feed it directly into
your machine or an algorithm like it'll
do the the transformations for you and
it also has an API that just takes care
of models and converts them into
tensorflow j/s models and allows you to
just run them in the browser so it's
incredibly
for this application is perfect because
I've got some tensor flow models or I've
got some carrots models and here is the
first one so we've got my shot or not
application I've built the Charis model
and I've got the I put here being shown
all in real time so this is all actually
running in my browser and you can see as
I shoot I'm doing the calculation of the
delta image all in the browser as well
and you see it spikes up when I shoot so
that's it there's also a little button
down here that says camera and what's
nice by this is I don't have everyone
ever try to use build camera
applications so this is this is very
over fit two basketball courts but the
closest thing we have where is so we
have the closest thing to a basketball
which is a loaf of bread so I don't I
need to it's a very over fit model it's
so over fit it only knows what I'm
shooting from this side of the screen so
you can see where it needs improving so
I'm going to attempt to it's such a good
model I'm going to attempt it needs it
needs to also think that I'm running
around I didn't I didn't train it on
blank images like here we go I'm gonna
throw it up there people imagine where
the basket is okay there we go
you guys fine thank you very alright
there's the shot or not model available
available on my github what's actually
catechol for that because it's all
tensorflow jazz it's all run in
JavaScript my production ization
platform is just the tenth or github
pages so if you I should go to the
github repo there's a link and it's all
running from github pages so yeah you
can productionize machinery in github
let's move on so we've got I've got I
know when I'm taking a shot or not the
idea is now I want to crop in where I'm
taking my shot from I could do an image
to image model that's a bit that's a bit
crazy to do that I could simplify it by
saying okay if I just know where to crop
it from that's useful and I can do the
rest of the cropping in code so I could
just imagine yeah X and Y axis
just tell me where the shot is taken
from so I need to predict two numbers
the x coordinate and the y coordinate of
the banks of the shot and I can just
encode say okay crop from this position
and the audio the audio the auto
cropping model then is not a
classification well it's actually just a
regression model and yeah where'd a shot
prick me two numbers though not just a
single number yeah two for x and y and
yep this is the way it's gonna be
applied I didn't actually know this when
I built it it is apparently called multi
target regression so yeah good thing to
know maybe you know where to crop it
from this is the data I did also do this
sort of time-wasting thing of writing my
own code to augment the data set left
right up down although in this case it
wasn't entirely wasted because if I were
to do it through the Charis API the key
I need to also augment the Y output in
this case so if I translate my image to
the left five pixels I need to also
translate the Y output to the left which
I don't believe the Charis API supports
if anybody knows any kind of data
augmentation tools that do do this
please tell me afterwards because this
was very hard to do the actual shot the
exact same as before because it's
predicting with the same input data I
don't see why I needed to change the
model at all the only thing I needed to
change the model was the output so
because I'm predicting two numbers it's
going to be two notes on a linear
activation that's going to give me two
regression outputs and moving swiftly on
the demo that demos this is similar sort
of thing very clean UI as you can see
I'm just going to wait for this to load
there we go
nope waiting for the video to load now
there we go
so we've got the video loading I've got
the output of my shot or not running at
the bottom and I also have the output of
my wear from model or the where's the
base of the shot happening you can see
it kind of just like doesn't know what
to do when I'm not shooting obviously
because it wasn't trained on data of
when I was not shooting it was only
trained on data when I was actually
making a shot so it only knows what to
do when it sees that nice clean arc and
you can see it kind of gets a bit
confused and then what as soon as I make
a shot it kind of jumps into action I
didn't add the news camera function to
this just to save myself a bit of
embarrassment but that is both those
models running in real time in the
browser as well and you can see I've got
the frame right here so it's but 50 60
FPS what's pretty cool about tense
approaches is that it's using OpenGL
under the hood so whatever device you're
using it's gonna try to use any kind of
graphical acceleration that the device
has to run these inferences a lot faster
so there's those two models running the
final thing is that I bring it all
together so I've got the trimming of the
video happening as a Karass model that I
built and productionize intense flow j/s
the cropping of the shot again built in
Karis production eyes intensive ljs and
the code I wrote at the start that
actually fit that linear model because
at the because the tentacle J's library
has a kind of carbon copy of the
original tensorflow library I just
reproduced that codes that say describe
a trajectory equation i just reproduce
at in javascript in the tensorflow
JavaScript syntax and that runs the
exact same way so the idea is that I
will use our feet in image it will say
okay am I making a shot if I am okay
where am I making a shot from okay cool
crop that and run my linear model to fit
to fit this line and then I just pluck
out the two variables that it's
optimized so the angle and the force and
it all runs inside a web page and here
is the final demo of layer loads in a
reasonable hour
here we go here we go alright so I've
got I know exciting I've got the video
at the top running you'll see a little
flash of a cross that's the where model
running and you see down here where
pretty is the data so it's the cropping
of the date at the bottom and then I
click this little checkbox and it's
going to run the model as well to fit
boom there we go so the angle of that
shot there was 52 degrees let's see how
consistent I am professionals are within
one degree of each shot 57 so I'm not a
professional and now I know that that is
that is that is he that is the entire
demo 53 again yeah
not good that's a terrier but thank you
all so much for listening
here's between Lola
a lot of questions yeah me too
does anybody have a question for Zach
come on there's a microphone on the seat
in front of you oh yeah yeah
hello yeah okay yeah just you were
asking these it leave your aggression
it's gonna be me I'm spying out go yeah
it's polynomial yes crew it's a load off
my chest
okay polynomial regression
did it help you get any better at
basketball so interestingly enough after
I finished building this I was already
bored of basketball
I'm moving on to new grounds I really
appreciate you create this so would you
use it to try to help yourself improving
the technique so that's a good question
so the idea is that this app that that I
I mean I came up with the use case
halfway through building it the idea was
that so long as it can measure how
consistent I am it's it's less of
helping me improve and we're just
keeping track of how well I'm improving
because the idea is that if you're a
consistent at shooting then you're a
better basketball player so yeah it's
less about improving your shot and we're
just tracking your progress
yeah yeah so I have yes so so the
question was I was capturing the the
shot in in just a 2d flat image and is
there an option to potentially if the
camera was it positioned differently to
capture a shot from three-dimensional
space or like considering the
three-dimensional space of the shot so
the idea is that if if you're able to
because as soon as you change the angle
that I did like I was very careful to
stay like perfectly flat to it to make
my life as easy as possible as soon as
you move like in a different angle the
trajectory equation won't fit anymore it
because it the direct to the the
trajectory equation only applies to like
a two-dimensional trajectory
I'm sure there's definitely a trajectory
equation for three-dimensional
trajectory that's then sort of I don't
know what you call it like projected
onto a two-dimensional plane so long as
you encode that in the tensor film model
it should be able to fit fit it so
whatever whatever a special new angle
that you start shooting the ball at as
long as you find an equation that
describes the the new curve you should
be able to just encode it in tensorflow
and it should just work it should do
yeah
yeah yeah it's definitely it's
definitely one of the many downsides of
this application oh yeah at the bank
have you tried to use just regular
scikit-learn for the trajectory curve
fitting in tensor flow or just fine so I
I didn't I didn't use tents for
Christmas fun
what do you scikit-learn fur for I
couldn't find I didn't know cuz the idea
was I wanted to find the angle of my
shot and I could fit just like a I don't
know like a neural network model or more
and more advanced polynomial model I
don't know how to make custom
polynomials in in scikit-learn so that
was the reason why actually do I I don't
know I didn't think about it long enough
so now I chose tensor field because I
thought that was the right solution but
now that I'm thinking about it maybe I
didn't have to use tents for though that
require a lot of training data I feel
and I would have to label the training
data well I I've considered that like
maybe cutting out some of the steps and
getting let me just have one neural net
well that tells me the angle actually I
could use this current model to take
some data and produce those labels and
then train that into another neural
network model so that would be a good
next step
yeah I could use this for the labeling
connection yeah it's a good idea
yeah what the back
hello yeah right see yeah I just had
this thought where if you're really
closer than they're your angle does have
to change
yeah yeah yeah did you manage to find
like a distance where that kind of
worked so the question was uh when you
get close to the to the net then you do
need to change your angle it doesn't
apply anymore
I didn't consider all the edge cases for
this the idea was a Freeth free-throw
shooting that's like one of the main
metrics of basketball like how good you
are how good you are from the free-throw
line and in that sort of area so yes I
didn't consider the edge cases of the
layups I believe they're called so in
theory it could because it's just
running on the web browser and you can
add in any kind of gamification you want
I'm kind of thing
I can't so like every time I tell people
just in person that I built this
basketball app and they say Oh does it
tell you when you make a shot I'm like
no but that have been much better okay
it can tell you the exact angle of your
shot though I can't think of a game that
does that I was thinking because there's
a database online that tells you the
exact angle of every professional
basketball there's a church shots and I
sit as thinking maybe you can you can
play and I can tell you not the angle
that you shoot at but who do you shoot
like so it's like yeah which could be
cool or you have to you know I honestly
don't know it was a very very not
thought through application yeah
can you hear okay so how I have a
question with respect to your negative
something
particle sampling the way how you sample
negatives instance the sampling yeah
okay
the the one with poopy poop and the one
with our boobs so if you sample like
although with our boobs like close to
sixty two degree would that be more
difficult to train the models so the
question was I sampled the hoop they
shot or not the the hips are not hopes
you say in the city no no I mean in the
degree like close to stick they 666
close to six series oh yeah so there is
a there yeah there's an insidious very
over fit I will admit that for example
you can see you can see also it shows
especially shows in the where I'm
shooting for a model because when it's
when I'm not doing anything it's it's
drifting towards the right-hand side of
the screen with the shot or not I tried
to augment the data as much as possible
and most of my shots were between sixty
and seventy degrees so I'm always
testing with with data out so those
ranges so it is almost definitely over
fits to where I'm shooting from and more
to that also the model that I train at
the end I set the default values of the
line that gets fit to close to 60 and 70
and yeah I cheated a lot in getting this
to work
yep
I I don't know their age data around
basketballers Heights and the anglers
that they shoot at and there is there is
apparently an optimal like there's a
there's a theoretical optimal angle of a
shot to make the basketball appear as
wide as possible and yeah there's a lot
of stuff around that so there's probably
an answer to that question but I don't
have it oh oh that's good so the idea is
that this is if you already know the
height of the person what is the
optimizer they should be shooting at
that's that is probably true and I guess
the the idea is this application will
tell you what you're currently shooting
at and you can use both of those metrics
to try to fit it together so yeah that's
a good like attachment to the app be
like oh you should be shooting at this
angle shoot at a higher angle actually
that would help improve so that would
yeah that would actually make the
application useful no but that's that's
actually no that's I should definitely
add that because that will actually make
it you can see the how much you should
change around goodbye so yeah that
that's a good thing thank you
[Applause]